[Music]
are the minimalists happy or upset that
elon musk bought twitter i don't care i
don't care
my goodness you're not allowed to not
care ryan you have to have a definitive
opinion silence is violence
dk what are your thoughts on elon musk
buying twitter
i mean just personally i literally felt
no emotion positive or negative about
that decision like my honest reaction
was oh interesting i know who elon musk
is
he does a lot of interesting stuff and
says a lot of interesting things
i have such a hard time knowing where
he's coming from because he just strikes
me as the kind of person that's playing
games half the time with what he tweets
like he's like
massively trolling people i have no idea
what he's thinking and what's going on
um but like
i
i didn't leap into like oh this is a
political victory for x
or or or or like oh this is a great
danger to society
i'm curious about it
and i'm interested in seeing
what this the social media space looks
like a year from now two years from now
um i i think there is danger in just
assuming that um everybody who seems to
be on your side in some kind of way is
some great champion of freedom every
time they do something like this look
for all i know because i've been around
and i've seen it happen before
two years from now the twitter
experience could be as anti-freedom as
people always thought it was and elon
musk is just
supporting the status quo that could be
the reality or for all i know 24 months
twitter could be like whoa i'm so glad
elon bought it but for me i respect
something that
i had and i valued and i grew a lot from
before i ever experienced any pressure
to be a thought leader and that is
i respect the space
of spending a lot of time observing and
meditating and contemplating before the
world knows what's going on in my heart
and mind so
i'll be happy to let you know what i
think about twitter you know after a
couple of years of observation and
experience and what i think the
difference is between elon musk but
right now
i literally feel no emotion about it and
i haven't even taken the time to read
what anybody else has to say like i
literally couldn't tell you what anybody
else thinks about it other than like
there's just the predictable
political reaction of a lot of people
feeling like oh this is bad a lot of
people feel like oh this is good but i
haven't even listened to a single
podcast or read a single article article
on it and it won't the topic that comes
up with this is censorship yeah and
freedom of speech and it's funny because
i am all about freedom of speech
and i love
that first amendment man i love that we
can say anything we want
without any repercussions
but there are a lot of people who i want
to shut the hell up
so me having if i had that power
uh
absolute power corrupts absolutely there
are certain people that would shut the
hell up you would just like delete the
account yeah i'd be like no sorry this
is a private business i do whatever i
want you're not welcome here bye yeah
yeah so so it's like it's funny but i
but i can recognize how
that's hypocritical
and you know with elon musk like yeah
like there are certain people that he's
probably not gonna you know ban from
twitter
um
like alex jones is a great example i
think that you know like i don't want to
hear what he has to say in fact i think
his
his lies and his the pedestal that he's
on has real life consequences
and those real life consequences affect
people in a negative way
um so yeah like i would shut him up but
i also see that that's counterintuitive
to freedom of speech so i mean
i i don't know what else to say except
like we're all hypocrite in some way and
i can see it in myself i don't really
know how to deal with it um but you know
i recognize the fact that like that's
one of the ways that i'm very
hypocritical well well there is the the
all-important private public distinction
right on a on a private platform so like
if you take like the purely voluntaries
or a libertarian position on freedom of
speech you could say hey in your store
in your home or on your platform where
you are the owner you get to set the
rules no matter how silly and
superficial they may be sure and so if
you want to say hey to come into my
restaurant you got to have a shirt on or
shoes or you're not allowed to swear or
even crack jokes or talk about
basketball
that's your right to say in my domain
that i own these are the rules and
you're free to not come on my domain
you're free to go give your money and
time and energy to a competitor so i
don't think it's hypocritical to say hey
if i owned a restaurant or if i owned a
platform i would only allow certain
people to set up an account whatever it
would make you unpopular it would make
you subject to criticism but that's all
part of the fair game of free speech
free speech doesn't mean
you
are immune from disagreement and social
ostracization it just means no one with
the threat of coercion no central
institution with the threat of coercion
has the power to find you or lock you up
for expressing your views so i don't
think there's any inherent hypocrisy
with that but you know what i would say
is that you know i think about quoting
cs lewis again that
he says it may be true
that some men deserve to be slaves but
no one amongst us no one among us
deserves to be a master and whenever i
think about like controlling speech and
censorship i always think to myself
certainly there are people that are
worthy to be censored but who among us
is worthy to be the censor
and
i don't think there's anybody out there
that's noble enough trustworthy enough
righteous enough or consistent enough to
be a worthy censor of ideas and so i'm a
big champion of sand
let all the crazy people talk
because i trust humanity's ability to
think critically about what they're
going to believe more than i trust some
central institutions ability to say no
no no we are the truth detectors uh
we're going to think critically for you
by not allowing you to have access to
these books or podcasts we know what's
best for you we're going to protect you
from being exposed to these lies oh yes
and who is it that gets to define lies
why us the trustworthy institution
imagine that being abused inconceivable
right
all you got to do is just imagine that
president that you didn't like four
years ago eight years ago 12 years ago
16 years ago trust me you ain't got to
go no further back than that imagine
what that power looks like in that
person's hand hmm
i'll tell you this
i think that
free speech is not self-evident right
and it's not a the right itself is not
self-evident it is also a construct
we've come up with yeah and so
what i will say is you know there are
certain neighborhoods in america right
now where you don't have free speech you
know all of your speech has consequences
you don't have to go somewhere far away
you can go to neighborhood i grew up in
or the trailer parks you grew up in
right yeah and your speech had
consequences real consequences yeah real
life immediate consequences
right and we all know and i'm not
encouraging anyone to go out and be vile
i'm simply saying this is what the
reality of the world is i think the
aspiration for free speech is something
that i certainly admire i like the idea
that any of us can say anything but the
problem is when any of us can say
anything all the time it creates this
giant trash heap and so elon musk buying
twitter is like well it depends on what
your perspective is if you love elon
musk then it's like one spray of febreze
on a trash heap
if you hate elon musk
it's a fart on a trash heap
either way it's not going to change
appreciably what's going on there
because yes you can censor alex jones
right but go back to the very beginning
of this
maximal episode of this private episode
ryan what were we talking about the
chinese farmer and alan watts and what
did alan watts say
you never know what will be the
consequence of the misfortune and you
never know what will be the consequences
of good fortune
so maybe you think this elon mustang is
great but it could end up being very
unfortunate for you or maybe you think
it's terrible and the consequence ends
up being something that seems amazing to
you long term and the truth is you
simply don't know right now even if
you're the biggest elon fan even if you
despise the man and wish he was never
born you want to heap all of these
denigrating monikers onto him
either way
you don't know and by the way twitter is
it's the best trash heap of all the
trash sheeps
right we have facebook and and instagram
and tick tock and
i prefer twitter to all of the other
mediums
even though it's the one
i think only five percent of the
minimalist followers are actually on
twitter we share stuff there all the
time
but when i look at the
when i look at the landscape
it's a lot of noise it's a lot of trash
and i don't want to contribute garbage
to that landscape no maybe elon comes in
and cleans up the trash heap i don't
know but it seems more likely that it's
not within his control
because of everything that's being
hurled in there is that even the
expectation though like
my context for this is that
the talk on censorship particularly with
social media really heated up at the
time when trump's accounts
were were suspended or deleted or
inactivated or whatever because that
that was a pretty unprecedented move in
our lifetime never had we had a
president or somebody like that
notorious
have have social media be like you're
off we're just turning your account off
we don't like what you're saying or we
we disagree we think you're dangerous
we're turning your account off that was
the first time and
there were a lot of people complaining
too
that they were losing followers that
their accounts were being suspended and
there were a lot of complaints from the
more conservative leaning side that like
hey they're like censoring our stuff
they're changing these algorithms and so
on so a lot of the people that
just on the surface who are celebrating
elon musk and free speech or saying like
all right
we're gonna get back to a point where
it's more of a free-for-all and hey you
disagree with me that's fine but i don't
have to worry about getting my account
suspended for disagreeing with joe biden
about something or something along those
lines i think
that was the impression i got like there
are certain topics your position on mask
mandates your position on a vaccine or a
position on binding certain topics where
if you express a certain kind of opinion
your account might be suspended or
deleted and i think a lot of people are
of certain views are excited because
they feel like maybe elon musk is going
to do less of that
yeah maybe he will maybe he won't i
haven't heard elon musk make a statement
promising anybody that so i mean it'll
be interesting to see how things unfold
he has made statements about it but
has he has he promised that he's going
to change that yeah yeah but you know
it's just interesting
because all of those censorship i i
think
they're actually i think it's good
intent you know but what do they say the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions yeah i mean i think you know
these platforms the the the powers that
be they think that they're preventing
harm from
uh falling on people
and uh
that's where it gets tricky because it's
like is it preventing
harm from falling on people or is it
just censoring people because like there
are certain things about covet and masks
that were getting censored a year ago
and then you know all of a sudden the
cdc has new information and they're like
oh
our perspective has changed
and now these things that were getting
censored a year ago they're allowed to
be on platforms because the cdc has said
okay yeah we agree with these things now
and yeah i mean there's i don't know
there's all these outliers that it's
hard it's not black or white that's
really what i'm trying to say like
there's a lot of outliers that
a lot of nuance that um
i don't think there's any human on this
planet that can sift through all the
nuance and make
the best decision that that uh that
leaves
or that that prevents harm from falling
on anyone yeah and yet who do we trust
to make sense of that nuance like it's
okay to seek out curators i go to
museums and they curate a museum but i'm
choosing
for to go to that museum and experience
that curation yes twitter is not a
curator
right and i think that's the difference
right if all of a sudden a art museum
came to my house and started moving
pictures around
i i would be incensed by that right
because yeah now you're
and i think it goes back to the
sunlight is the greatest disinfectant
because for me when i see
alex jones i see him as a comedian i
don't know how people take him seriously
i think one of the reasons they do take
him seriously though
is as soon as he's censored it makes
people think like well wait a minute
yeah uh what do we do we're censoring
the truth right i think the best way to
expose someone like alex jones is what
andrew schultz did former podcast guest
of ours that he brought him on his
podcast and let him just pontificate for
two hours and all of a sudden you i saw
like
oh who would i would never take this
seriously now but if all this was
censored i'm gonna it piques my
curiosity hmm i wonder what he is what
he's saying what are they hiding
yeah i think the best way to make a
conspiracy theory sound or look credible
is to
censor it
and and try to make the information
inaccessible because the conspiracy
theory is going to be based on an us
against them mentality that says this is
the stuff they don't want you to know
every conspiracy theory is based on that
presupposition this is something they
don't want you to know and you validate
that you reinforce it make people more
curious about it but you know i've
always thought that um
[Music]
conspiracy theories are a great
invitation a great opportunity to engage
in philosophy because what a conspiracy
theory essentially does it says here's
the mainstream story that you're told
about something important
and here's a theory about how that's a
lie and you're being deceived and i
think it's a great opportunity for
people to accept the challenge of saying
okay
i totally am free to disagree with this
conspiracy theory let's just make that
the default laughing at it as the
default but let's earn our right to
laugh at bad ideas why do you think it's
false
because it's not just about what you
believe it's about how you hold that
belief and why you hold that belief and
i think conspiracy theorists
can challenge us in a healthy way
to make us say all right i disagree with
what he's saying i accept the mainstream
story but but why why do i think that
person's wrong i always think that's a
valuable
enterprise and i don't think human
beings should be protected from it i
think human beings should be encouraged
to do it um that doesn't mean that you
know as parents for instance or as
teachers when we're dealing with minors
that we just let them watch whatever
they want on tv we want to protect them
in the sense of teaching them the
principles of critical thinking until
they get to an age of like watching
certain types of things or consuming
certain types of content but i'm
actually a big fan of bringing it all
into the light and saying let's have
public discussions about this
controversial conspiratorial view
because if it's nonsense bringing it out
into the light will expose it we don't
have to run from it we don't have to be
afraid of it but if there's some truth
to it perhaps we can learn because every
generation has commonly accepted truths
that were a conspiracy to previous
generations did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free